greetings everyone this is Rob Sanders
from simply learned and today we're
going to talk about how to rank number
one on Google so let's get started and
let's go with the scenario that you have
a friend named Sam and he has a website
where he sells shoes but Sam doesn't
understand why his websites not ranking
number one on Google and so typically
the ranked number one on Google there
are some factors involved and those are
factors that are going to help Sam get
his website ranked number one on Google
so he can sell his shoes get traffic and
convert that traffic to conversions so
there are factors involved and so what
are those factors well it always starts
with keyword research so in order to
rank for a website where you sell shoes
or you sell products other products like
clothing or food or your automobile
website you know your mechanic it
doesn't matter whether you're selling to
customers or selling to other businesses
you have to start with the keyword
research and so we're gonna go into
really explicit detail on how to conduct
a proper keyword research and then the
second factor involved is high quality
content so in order to rank high on
Google search you need to have high
quality content so we're gonna go over
what's involved with creating high
quality content then we're going to take
that content we're going to optimize it
using on-page elements and website level
factors so we're gonna take into account
what's involved with your website and
what's involved with specific pages on
your website in order to rank number one
on Google then we're going to get into
the off-site engagement so when it comes
to ranking on Google you need to
optimize your website and you need to do
some elements off your website you need
to be engaging off your website meaning
on other websites and so we're going to
talk about what's involved with off side
engage
so SEO being a major channel for most
companies and websites where the
opportunity to drive a lot of traffic is
there but you have to earn that reward
the reward is a lot of traffic but you
have to earn the reward and there's a
lot of work involved and so ideally what
we want to do is follow what we call the
8020 rule when it comes to search engine
optimization and ranking on Google and
what do we mean by the 80/20 rule
well 80/20 means we're investing 20% of
our effort and 80% of the results are
obtained so we want to invest 20 and get
back 80 that's basically me about 8020
so for example if 20% of our targeted
keywords bringing 80% of the traffic
then that's following the 8020 rule or
20% of our landing pages drive eighty
percent of the overall traffic that's
following the 8020 rule or 20% of our
backlinks passed 80 percent of our link
juice that's the 8020 rule meaning these
cargo two keywords these targeted
landing pages these trying to target
backlinks using off-site engagement we
want to put in 20% of our effort on
those keywords landing pages and
backlinks in return for 80% of the
results so without further ado let's get
started with the keyword research let's
talk about that keyword research for a
website with shoes and it doesn't really
matter what particular product you have
if you need to rank number one on Google
it all starts with the keywords as I
mentioned before and so in this example
if you have a website where you sell
shoes for kids you're going to want to
be found for certain keywords so the
obvious keyword here would be shoes for
kids well every keyword that you target
has search volume associated with it so
that means when we talk about search
volume we're talking about how many
people on average type in that keyword
or related keyword on google.com or
Google search and there's always an
average number of searches Assoc
with every keyword and we call that
search volume how much search volume so
obviously if we're gonna target a
keyword we want to have as much fun as
possible however there's always going to
be competition for those keywords
meaning there's always going to be other
websites you want to rank number one on
Google for the same keywords and we call
that competition or difficulty so for
every keyword you're going to have
volume and you're going to have
competition or difficulty and the
difficulty ranges as well depending on
the tool you use and we'll get into that
in a minute but search volume is how
much on average people are typing in
that keyword or closing variants of that
keyword and the difficulty is measured
in terms of how many other websites are
trying to rank for the same keyword and
so ideally when it comes to keyword
research we want to find that nice
balance we want high volume and we want
low competition but at the same time we
want to focus on keywords that are
highly relevant to our business so if
we're selling shoes for kids and shoes
for kids is highly relevant has high
volume in low competition then that's a
keyword we want to target so we always
want to focus in on those three areas so
there's always a trade-off with keywords
so shoes for kids might have high volume
but also might have high competition or
difficulty if we look for another
keyword that's just as relevant for
example shoes for children it may still
have high search volume but the
competition or the difficulty may be
lower and if that's the case then that
might be a better keyword for us to
target instead of something highly
competitive like shoes for kids we can
focus on another relevant keyword like
shoes for children with just as much
volume and lower competition and the
reason why we want lower competition is
because we want to be able to rank for
that keyword so the higher the
competition the harder it is for us to
rank number one on google for that
keyword and so the whole idea beyond
keyword research is analyzing and
choosing the best
so we want to identify a list of key
words that are always relevant we want
to choose the keyword that your
competitors are ranking for and we want
to use third party tools to choose
keywords to identify which keywords have
low competition and what keywords have
high search volume so one thing to take
into consideration when you're doing
keyword research is that the longer the
keyword phrase or in other words
longtail keywords or keywords with three
keywords in the phrase or more you're
gonna always have less competition but
there's always a trade-off with longtail
keywords meaning the longer the keyword
phrase there's gonna be less volume but
the trade-off is less competition and so
what we want to do is we want to
brainstorm some ideas and find those
relevant keywords so let's look at an
example here so if we go to Google ads
so Google ads has a total keyword
planner and let's just say I have a a
website where I'm selling dried figs and
if I'm selling dry figs I want people to
buy these dried figs however in order to
attract them I want to be able to show
them at hey we have a bunch of recipes
and if I show you a bunch of recipes
where you can use dried figs maybe
you'll buy these dried figs too using
these recipes and so we're gonna look
for keywords related to bread recipes
because if we can optimize for our
recipes page for bread then that will
attract an audience who wants to make
bread and use dried figs with those
bread recipes so that's the example I'm
going to give here and so if I look at
the keyword planner in Google Ads if I
just type in bread recipes what Google
is going to do is you're going to give
me an average monthly search volume so I
can see the average monthly search
volume here is sixty thousand five
hundred and so in order to do keyword
research what I would recommend is keep
a spreadsheet and so the idea behind the
spreadsheet is to document the volume
and the competition you're getting for
certain keywords so if I go into a
spreadsheet here my theme
keywords is bread recipes my keyword is
bread recipes and my volume therefore is
going to be sixty thousand five hundred
however if I go back into Google's
keyword planner Google's telling me the
competition is low so that's great I
want a high volume I want low
competition but how low is low so we
want to be careful so if we're going to
put in numbers into a spreadsheet we
want to figure out what that competition
really is for the keyword bread recipes
so if I go to Google and just type in
bread recipes I'm gonna be able to see
seven hundred and seventy-one billion
results for the keyword bread recipes
now these seven hundred and seventy-one
billion are real competition maybe maybe
not what we want to do is put in a
syntax and we want to put in the syntax
all in title and then colon space and
then our keyword and the reason why we
do that in search is because we want to
be able to identify the true competitive
number or the true number of websites or
trying to rank for bread recipes and if
we put in the syntax all in title colon
and then our keyword bread recipes we'll
be able to see that there are nine
hundred and ninety thousand results
that's a lot lower than seven hundred
seventy one billion so that means that
nine hundred ninety eight thousand sites
or listings have the keyword bread
recipes in the title tag and the title
tag is what shows up in the search
engine results and so if I look down and
scroll down here I can see bread recipes
or every one of these title tags so
title tag is an important element to
rank number one on google and we'll talk
about that in a few minutes but if we
understand that they're nine hundred
ninety eight thousand results with bread
recipes in the title tag then this tells
us that those are the websites who are
trying to rank number one on google for
that keyword and therefore those are the
websites we need to jump over in order
for our website to
number one on Google and so therefore
I'm gonna put in 998 thousand in my
spreadsheet as the competitive number
and so now I could see for the keyword
bread recipes I have sixty thousand five
hundred and if my competition is nine
hundred ninety thousand then my Kei or
keyboard effectiveness index or in other
words the ratio of volume to competition
is six percent so that's nothing more
than volume divided by competition so
that tells me that my Kei
or my ratio between volume competition
is six percent so remember we want more
volume than we want competition so
anytime you do a keyword research you're
going to find a number of different
relevant keywords so if I go back into
Google's keyword planner if I typed in
bread recipes you could see that Google
is going to give me a number of
different keywords related to bread
recipes let's just say I have another
keyword that I want to think about
optimizing for being ranked on Google
for and that's banana bread recipe very
similar keyword as bread recipes except
it's a little longer town now if I type
in banana bread recipe in Google's
keyword planner now I can see the
average monthly search volume has
actually gone up
it's three hundred and sixty eight
thousand I can also see the competition
is low so those are good signs so now I
can see three hundred sixty eight
thousand I'm gonna go ahead and put that
in my spreadsheet now I'm gonna go into
Google I'm gonna put in my syntax all in
title I'm gonna put in banana bread
recipe I'm going to hit enter and now I
can see I have two hundred and thirty
three thousand results with the keyword
banana bread recipe in the title tag so
if I look at the title tags I can see
banana bread recipe banana bread recipe
banana bread recipe on all the listings
in the Google search results so that
tells me I have two hundred and thirty
three thousand results that I have to
jump over in order to rank number one on
Google so I'm going to put two hundred
thirty three thousand
my spreadsheet now I can see my Kei or
my volume to competition ratio is 157
158 % and so to me that's a lot better
number to work with or in other words
that's a lot better keyword because it's
just as relevant and it has a higher
ratio of volume to competition
so therefore banana bread recipe is
going to be a better keyword to optimize
for in order to rank number one on
Google so that's the whole idea behind
keyword research you want to brainstorm
ideas there are plenty of tools out
there so the tool I recommend is Google
Ads keyword planner Google's gonna give
you how much search volume they're going
to tell you the competition but then
you're gonna go into Google search
you're gonna use the syntax all in title
to get a more accurate read on the
actual competitive number and so to find
out how keywords that your competitors
are ranking for you can use those
keyword tools that I mentioned another
tool that I use is Moz
so Moz if you go to moz.com they have a
tool called keyword explorer so if we
just type in the keyword for example
read recipes it's going to be able to
tell us how much volume and the
difficulty so you can use other tools at
your disposal figure out the volume and
the difficulty there are plenty of tools
out there but the one thing I would just
make sure is you use everything at your
disposal so you can use social media to
find the most shared article for a
particular topic or keyword like bread
recipes you could check other platforms
that have a lot of shared content like
Reddit and Cora where you can ask people
about certain topics using keywords to
figure out how much competition or
volume there might be you can stay up to
date on industry news to get an idea of
what types of keywords are trending but
it when it comes to keywords and keyword
research remember for every webpage we
want to be able to pick two keywords we
want a primary inside
Andheri keyword so when we do keyword
research and we enter all our keywords
into our spreadsheet we want to be able
to have a number of different keywords
in this case we're focusing on the theme
bread recipes we want to have different
keywords because we want to be able to
choose a primary keyword and a secondary
keyword because we want to be able to
focus on multiple keywords for each page
because we don't want to put necessarily
all our eggs in one basket meaning we
won't want to put our emphasis just on
one keyword to rank for we want multiple
keywords to try and rank for so the
primary keyword can define the nature of
our business
the secondary keyword could be just
highly relevant to our keyword at the
end of the day we want to choose
multiple keywords to try and rank on
Google for that page so for example we
have a blog and we're using ice cream
recipes and we're blogging about ice
cream recipes we can have a primary
keyword that is about ice cream recipes
or homemade ice cream recipes we're
gonna always want to find out what the
volume and the competition is our
secondary keyword could be built around
other similar keywords like low-fat ice
cream recipes or fat-free ice cream
recipes or low-fat homemade ice cream
recipes those are complementary keywords
just like our bread recipes and banana
bread recipe so one thing we want to do
when we do keyword research is we want
to be able to target one keyword per
content when you can target many we want
to be able to target multiple keywords
not necessary target one keyword and so
we want to be able to cluster keywords
see we don't want to target just one we
want to target multiple keywords per
page and when we talk about clustering
if we go back to our keyword research
what we're doing is we're clustering a
bunch of keywords under the theme bread
recipes and so by looking at the volume
looking at the competition looking at
the Kei we can choose different keywords
for our page and that's what we mean by
clustering we want to cluster Kiwi
into a Content 3 so why target only one
keyword per content when we can target
many because we don't want to put all
our eggs in one basket we don't want to
target just one keyword we want to
target many and so that means clustering
your keywords into a theme and choosing
multiple keywords for that particular
page and when we do that we have a
better opportunity to rank high on
Google search and the whole idea behind
ranking high in Google Search is we can
get the volume so if we know we're
ranked number one on Google search for
bread recipes or banana bread recipe we
know we stand a chance of getting a
majority of the volume associated with
that keyword and if we can get the
volume and get the traffic then we can
get the conversions so let's move on to
high quality content and talk about the
impact content has on your ability to
get your website ranked number one on
Google so let's just say you have
content on your website and the content
is ranking on you page four of Google
and it's that blog with ice cream
recipes and if it's just content for the
sake of content is not really
informative then it's not necessarily
gonna get good engagement in the eyes of
Google you know they want to rank
content that's very informative it's
very fresh it's exciting to read it's
interesting it's going to have good
engagement so if it's a recipe or an
article about any topic if it's the
content is just not informative then
you're not gonna get good engagement and
when you don't get good engagement if
people don't stay on the site to engage
in the content and they just leave the
website after landing on the page
causing a bounce then the content is
just gonna continue to fall down the
rankings and we want to prevent that we
want to move up the rankings we want to
be number one on Google we don't
necessarily want to fall in the rankings
for our content so content is a key
driver in being able to rank number one
Google so if the content is on page nine
what can we do
well we want to be able to you know take
that content and do something we'll put
that we feel like we did right engaging
content so let's go ahead and share it
on social media and to me social media
is a good platform to share your content
because on social media platforms like
Facebook for example you're building a
community on that platform that
community is already interested in your
content so if you're sharing an ice
cream recipe especially in the
summertime and you're engaging with your
community on that platform then the
likelihood of that community on that
platform is going to increase engagement
increased engagement will send social
signals to the search engine that says
hey this content is good quality
likewise for any other platform most
social media platforms have engagement
metrics and those engagement metrics
pass signals is it good is it not good
do we like this content are we giving it
a thumbs up or are we going to want to
follow it are we gonna want to share it
and so if you share content that you
feel is engaging on social platforms
then it's going to be engaging and it's
likely going to cause an increase in
engagement for example and decrease and
bounce it and once you share that
quality content then the likelihood of
it moving up the rankings even as far as
number 1 on Google is going to be
greater so you always want to start out
writing good quality content so let's
talk about good quality content because
Google does take content seriously they
do take into account what other people
think of that content so high quality
content is an important factor so how to
create good content that's always the
question so let's talk about some best
practices here remember and the last
segment we talked about keyword research
so we want to perform good keyword
research why cuz we want to choose
keywords remember we're choosing
multiple keywords per page one keyword
could be related to our brand one
keyword could be related to the
but another keyword could be related to
a user's intent like recipes if you
recall the example we use with bread
recipes maybe somebody's looking to type
in a keyword that says how do I make you
know a bread or how do I make a specific
type of bread or how do I make banana
bread or what's the best recipe for
banana bread their question related and
we want to be able to answer this
question so that's where choosing those
right keywords that's going to respond
to a user's intent so starts with
choosing the right keywords so remember
we talked about a number of different
tools when we talk about keyword
research so there's a research tool that
you can use called phrase IO and that
will help you do quick research on you
know key words and trends and whatnot so
if you know a better research tool that
you use for keyword research then drop
us a comment below I'd be interested in
getting your comments about keyword
research and what research tools are out
there so if you know something better
than phrase dot IO drop a comment below
and we'd be interested in getting your
perspective so keyword research is key
but creating content the fulfils users
requirements so answering those
questions it's a recipe we want to
answer that question if it's directions
we want to answer that question if they
don't know how to do something we want
to answer that question then that's the
whole idea behind content content is not
just to fill a page it's to really
fulfill users requirements that's when
you get good engagement so if somebody's
typing in something on Google and
they're looking for an answer your
content should answer that question but
we also want to make the content
readable so in other words you know
right for your audience don't impress
anybody with very high vocabulary type
words that somebody doesn't necessarily
know the meaning of don't use jargon
don't use a street language for example
use everyday common language that's just
easily digestible when your audience is
reading and then we want to keep that
content organized and so we mean
organize we want to use headers and sub
headers you know break your content and
keep the flow organized if we can keep
the flow organized then it's gonna be
easier for somebody to read and then
it's okay to add resources especially
resources from credible sites so if you
can incorporate those resources in there
then it's just gonna add the credibility
to your content let the audience know
that hey I've done my research on this
topic and this is what this person has
to say about it
this person who seems to be credible
okay so it only adds value to your
content so these are all tips to
remember when creating content and then
the one important tip here is we want to
use white hat techniques and when we say
white hat techniques that means you know
if we chosen keywords that are gonna
answer somebody's question we don't want
to stuff those keywords into the content
we want the content to be naturally
written so when we say opt for white
hecht techniques that's what we mean
write the content naturally keep it
organized keep it readable include
third-party sources and make sure it
answers a question so there are
different types of content so there's
content where you just write words -
it's all text-based
you could also use an infographic an
infographic is simply just a graphic
that visualizes exactly what you're
trying to explain for example if we want
to write an article about how to write
good engaging content we don't
necessarily have to write all that out
of text we can create an infographic so
for example here's an infographic on 20
effective ways to basically not bore
your readers but write engaging content
so you can see this is an infographic
it's all graphically laid out so
infographics tend to be easier to
understand because they're visual
they're easy for the end user to
comprehend because there's generally no
jargon it's usually images that are
portraying the points of what you're
trying to get across and so it tends to
break it up the monotony of just text
it's more visually appealing and it's
laid out and organized so you can see
this infographic has 20 different steps
or rules and they lay the
is out all here in this infographic and
the great thing I like about
infographics is you could share them on
social media you can re-engage them as a
post you can save them um really any
social platform so infographics tend to
tell a better story and versus say just
writing text you can use video and
images so you don't necessarily have to
lay it all out in an infographic you can
certainly insert a video or an image
into your content especially if it's a
blog post if it's a blog post then
sometimes video and images on its own
tell the story you don't necessarily
need text to go ahead and tell your
story a video or an image as they say
tells a thousand words and so images and
videos are great to use in a blog post
so using different forms of content you
know you always want to review your
content when a user dwells on your
webpage for a longer time Google will
tend to think okay this person is
engaged so we're going to rank that
favorable so if you're using
infographics videos and images then the
chances of somebody being more engaged
or going to increase versus just text
that's not well organized and written
out in a way that somebody doesn't
necessarily understand so be creative
and the types of content you use so
longer engaging content tends to bode
well with search engines so this is a
cortina HubSpot so the more word count
you use the more words you use the
chances of you ranking higher are going
to be better just take into account best
practices you want to maybe break up the
content with an image organize it make
it engaging use headers so it's not
necessarily just words it's the words
and how those words are written how
they're structured the types of keywords
you're using how you're engaging with
your audience there's a lot of factors
again there's best practices we just
went over but the key is you know if you
have longer more engaging content then
it's going to bode better for you
on search engines so a couple of steps
to create high quality content so you
want to begin with a comprehensive
introduction
so always introduce your content
remember the content should be relevant
to the keywords so if you're choosing
keywords and your keyword research think
about answering that question if
somebody's typing in bread recipes maybe
they're looking for banana bread recipes
how to make the best than Ana bread or
how to make banana bread using dried
figs we want to be able to align our
content with that keyword naturally you
want to create a title that's worthy
that's click worthy so remember if
you're in Google search and you're doing
search for something simple like bread
recipes we want to sell make something
that's gonna be you know engaging for
somebody to click on like easy perfect
yeast bread or easy crusty French bread
or something that's gonna be engaging
you know the best bread recipes or how
to make the best homemade bread you know
something that's going to draw
somebody's attention to the title of
that blog post so we want to include LSI
keywords so what I mean by LSI keywords
and your content
we mean you know longtail keywords make
it natural headings and subheadings
should consist of key words and variants
so if you're writing headers and sub
headers include the key word in there
and that way the content always stays
relevant to the audience
okay shorten your sentences and
paragraphs so don't write long
paragraphs remember we want to break
this up we want to make it easy for the
end-user to read and we want to always
put internal links on our blog post why
because if we have internal links then
if we have a link from one blog post to
another blog post or say our blog post
to an internal page on our website we
want to make sure that it's relevant
content that way somebody's reading
something and you have an internal link
let's just see from a bread recipes page
to a banana bread recipes page then they
may find it interesting click on that
link and go to the banana bread recipes
page so we
keeping somebody engaged on your website
so putting in internal linking will help
it keep the end user engaged because
you're offering up links that's relevant
to the content you always want to break
up that content with images okay we want
to use alt tags meaning we want to pan
the image with text so that way if the
image doesn't load then at least the alt
text will load so we can incorporate
call-out boxes and more importantly we
want to update our content regularly so
we always want to get the best recipe
out there if it's banana bread or
different ways to crepe it in a bread or
are always just coming up with ways to
update the content so we want to keep
our content or blog post fresh and then
we want to include a CTA call to action
if we include a call to action then
that's going to keep somebody engaged
and have them act on your content so
these are steps to creating high quality
content and so let's look at an example
here and this is a three month old post
on BuzzFeed and it's 21 pictures that
restore your faith in humanity so it has
a lot of likes a lot of tweaks and that
means it's engaged people are engaged
when reading that and so if we go and
look at it as an example we could see it
on a BuzzFeed here 21 pictures that will
restore your faith in humanity so this
was written back in 2012 again a lot of
engagement but if we look at it we can
see immediately that it's taking into
account third-party sources it's got
some content Scot images it's being
broken up by images we can see there's
call to actions on there in the form of
social so people can go ahead and go
ahead and share it if they like it okay
it includes videos includes images
third-party sources so it's a good post
because listen you know it's engaging
content it's probably answering
somebody's question about humanity and
we could see clearly that look you know
there's a lot of different examples here
from a lot of different sources and we
could
take action on this content so nachos
video not just images but text as well
and so it's very engaging answers
questions takes into account the
different types of content available so
this is a good post in that regard so
contents updated regularly it's engaging
and it includes sources from high
authority websites some do's and don'ts
on the content so take into account the
best practices I mentioned about
creating high quality content they
answer those questions that the end user
wants to hear you know because that
likely is going to be their search and
so you want to be able to respond to the
end user that's part of creating high
quality content different types of
content ie in the form of infographics
or videos or text or images you can add
images from public domain sites you can
be relatable and use examples to clarify
points just like the BuzzFeed article
simplify complex words don't use
sophisticated language talk to your
audience as if you they were standing
right in front of you and use bullet
points to exemplify your examples your
points so some do's the don'ts obviously
don't lift content we don't want to lift
content from another website so that's
plagiarism so we want to have our own
unique content we also don't want to
take images from other websites and so
if you do happen a fine an image that
works for your post and it's on somebody
else's website ideally that's not a good
situation but if you do happen to do
that then always give credit to the
website okay so if you took it from
xyz.com credit XYZ calm for the image
and even put a link back but ideally you
don't want to take images from other
websites just as much as you don't want
to take copy you don't want to take
images use your own imagery and content
but if you don't have imagery then you
can always go to stock photography there
are plenty of websites out there where
you can sign up for a subscription like
Adobe stock images
an example you could sign up for an
account and in some cases you can sign
up for a free account and use stock
imagery okay don't give less information
to your audience given to your audience
what they deserve which is the
information they're looking for they're
looking for the best banana bread
recipes give them the best banana bread
recipes incorporate your own images
break it up with titles give them a good
quality piece of content that they're
going to be able to engage with and so
if you put long paragraphs and you're
content then it's going to be less
engaging so try to avoid those long
paragraphs remember shorten up the
paragraphs keep the language simple
added images answer those questions use
third-party credible sources but write
it in your own words and you should be
on your way to creating good quality
content okay so now that we've talked
about high quality content in order to
get your pages ranked high on Google
search let's turn our attention to
optimizing on page elements and discuss
some website level factors that are both
going to help you rank high on Google
search so let's just do an overview of
what we're talking about when we talk
about on-page elements and website level
factors so optimizing on-page elements
include a number of different things but
primarily we're gonna focus in on meta
tags also known as meta description tags
header tags also known as title tags in
URLs so those are just some of the
on-page elements we want to be able to
optimize using relevant keywords in
order to rank on Google search we also
want to take a look at some website
factors that will affect our ranking on
Google search they include website
architecture having a secure website
having a sitemap and taking a look at
page speed so all of those are some of
the website factors we need to take into
account in order to rank high on Google
search so title tag and meta description
together are considered meta tags
so both play an important role in
ranking high on Google so we want to be
able to write unique title and
descriptions for each page on our
website
when I say unique that means a title in
the Meta Description
need to be different for every page on
the website and so if you're not quite
sure what a title tag in a Meta
Description tag is if you go to search
and just type in any particular search
query the title tag is what's going to
show up here and bold and then the
description is going to show up below it
below the URL and that's going to
describe the page so both of these meta
tags are important because it describes
what your page is all about and that's
what Google uses in the search results
pages so we want to be able to pay
attention to the length of our meta tags
so if we go back to our search results
pages met title tags are generally 60 65
characters Meta Description tags are
generally a hundred and sixty characters
so anything really longer than that then
what's going to happen is the Meta
Description tag or the title tag will
get truncated and so if we look here for
example we can see all of the title tags
here fit the 65 character limit but if
you run over the character count Meta
Description then Google is going to
truncate the copy so you want to stay
within your parameters in order to avoid
getting your content truncated and so
the other thing when we're writing title
Meta Description tags we want to
minimize keyword repetition so if we're
optimizing for keyword we don't want to
necessarily just plug that keyword into
the title tag a meta description
multiple time we want to make sure our
title tags and meta descriptions are
naturally written so if somebody's
typing for banana bread recipe with
dried figs you know we want to have a
nice title tag and into this description
that is going to get somebody to respond
based on their need and so we definitely
want to avoid keyword repetition but we
want to be able to use that
in the title tag because if you remember
from the earlier segment when we did the
all in title syntax to find out exactly
how many competitors were using that
particular keyword well we obviously
want to use that keyword in the title
tag because again the title tags an
important factor when it comes to search
engine results so we want to use the key
word but we want to avoid stuffing or
using it repetitively in our title tag
in our Meta Description we want the
title tag and the Meta Description to
describe the page sound natural but also
be engaging because the point is we want
people to click on our link and go to
our website from search engines so title
tags with numbers tend to results in
higher click-through rates this is
according to Moz
so for example if you just put in a
title tag that says learn digital
marketing well that may work but if you
put a number in there like five easy
ways to learn digital marketing that
might get somebody to click on your link
and go to your website so having
questions in your meta tags can also
increase your click-through rate for
example if you just put learn the
importance of first page rankings not
too bad but again generic but if you put
it into the formal question how to rank
number one on Google it's more
action-oriented it's going to get
somebody to resonate with the question
that they have and that may be either a
query how to rank number one on Google
and so these techniques will help you
get higher click-through rates and so
according to backlinko title tag with a
keyword can improve site ranking so
remember we want to include that keyword
in the title tag even though we only
have 65 characters we want to include
that keyword but we want to avoid
stuffing the keyword in there we want to
again make the title tag action-oriented
maybe with the number maybe as a
question with the keyword in there once
naturally not easy to do but that's the
beauty of SEO if you can follow these
best practices and write a good title
tag
then the chances of you improving in
your search results are going to be
greater
so having only one h1 tag in your post
is going to be good
so remember when somebody clicks on a
link so let's say they do find a title
tag engaging and they click on this this
link here and they go to that website
you know you want to start out with
having that particular h1 tag because
the h1 tag especially with the keyword
in it is going to signal to Google hey
we're organizing our page and because
it's an h1 tag it's important we're
structuring the page according to best
practices so having only one h1 tag in
your post is definitely helpful having
multiple tags H tags in your post helped
organize the page a lot better so we
want to add that targeted keyword in
that tag and your tighter tags should be
relevant to the content so if we go back
to our example of the using dried figs
with banana breads well the title says
California fig banana bread and remember
the last segment when we're talking
about high-quality content well look no
further than including a video into our
content so not only will this video help
keep the engagement high but it breaks
up the monotony of the page and it's
from a third-party source so it adds
credibility to the page so adding a
videos based on the last segment of
high-quality content
definitely helps with ranking high on
Google search so following hierarchical
structure that means putting those H
tags in there h2 tags help break up the
content and we want to avoid repetition
of h1 tags on your different web pages
of your site meaning don't just put the
same h1 tag with the same keyword in it
and keeping it blase we want to make
those h1 tags exciting to read but also
used appropriately to break up the
content to remember all white hat
techniques we want to avoid hidden tags
we want to avoid stuffing keywords we
want things to be natural we all want
things to be forced
and your h1 tag should be 20 to 70
characters don't make long h1 tags if we
go back to our page example a short
sweet tag here California pig banana
bread it's relevant to the content it's
short sweet and it breaks up the
monotony of the content and more
importantly and again any Content you
have on the page should always answer
the users intent remember people are
using search to answer questions find
information our content should be able
to answer that for them so according to
John Muller Senior webmaster trends
analyst at Google header tags would
definitely help Google for rankings and
the search results so we want to use
header tags so when it comes to URLs we
want to use hyphens and avoid
underscores so if we look at this URL
here this uses hyphens fig and banana
bread so it's all broken up with hyphens
that's a best practice remember
canonical URLs a canonical URL signals
to Google this is the original content
so we want to use original content and
if you have multiple sources of content
out there on say different web sites we
want to use a canonical tag to signal to
Google this is the original content
please Index this content and not
doesn't hurt to use a favicon in URL
meaning a small icon and helps to break
up the monotony and help your URL stand
out we can add targeted keywords in the
URL so again looking at the URL here I
can see we're using targeted keyword as
part of the URL structure Fagin mañana
Brett and known as the h1 tag is fake
banana bread so it's all consistent and
it flows naturally URLs that are no
longer existing then we want to be able
to set up a redirect for those URLs
meaning a 301 redirect is a server
response for Google that says hey Google
this page is no longer available but if
we permanently redirected it to this
page which is now available so that's
what a 301 redirect does it helps signal
to Google and all the other search
engines that if the page is no
that's fine you're just going to go to
this page this is the page that's
permanently there now and another thing
we want to do here is if you have mobile
URLs you want to include those in the
sitemap and we're gonna hit on that in
just a minute but all URLs should be
mobile-friendly as well as that's not
friendly
meaning take into account this best
practices keep your well short use
hyphens put the keyword in the URL and
make it easy to understand one avoid
capital letters in the URLs the URLs are
case sensitive so go lowercase you
should always go lowercase from the URL
readable URLs again the rule of thumb
here is if you understand what the URL
is then Google is going to understand
what the URL is so the shorter the URL
the easier it is to read the easier it
is to read the better chance you have to
rank high on Google search so according
to backlink to URLs that are shorter
definitely definitely help you rank so
we want to be able to shorten those URLs
keep them short and sweet
don't make them long and unreadable so
those are some on optimized ways or
on-page elements that help you optimize
now we want to look at some website
level factors that will help you
optimize and rank high on Google search
so good site structure provides better
crime for search engine BOTS and what do
we mean by that when we mean having your
site organized in a fashion that Google
is going to be able to find all the
pages so what do we mean by that create
a logical hierarchy structure so if
you're selling shoes you know you're
gonna have a home page break the
structure up into men's shoes women's
shoes children's shoes then under men
shoes you can have it by brand it could
be Nike Puma adidas on the women's side
it could be Nike Puma adidas on the
child side it could be Nike Puma adidas
and so you want to keep the structure
flow in a hierarchy do we want to
balance the amount of subcategories
within each category so the men's if it
has Nike Puma adidas the women should
have Nike
Puma adidas and so you want to code your
site navigation and CSS or HTML meaning
we want to be able to use something that
Google is going to be able to index so
most sites are built in HTML and that's
what Google likes to index they like to
index something that they could take
back to their servers and then more
importantly build a comprehensive
structure for internal linking so
internal links meaning that if you're on
a site you should have natural links
pointing to other pages on your website
so to keep the flow going and we don't
want to have unnatural inbound links you
always want to have natural internal
links to keep the flow of the user going
from one page to the other so here I can
see as an example all the ingredients in
this recipe well this has an internal
link to another page on our site and
this happens to link to page where
somebody can buy the ingredient so it's
a natural internal link so John
Dougherty of credo has claimed that one
of the biggest changes that he can make
and fixing the Credo website is
architecture so for example in credo
John dirty has increased the organic
sessions by 74 percent of pages by per
session by 41 percent just by changing
the site architecture so you'd be
surprised by changing the site
architecture what that will do to
engagement and so let's turn our
attention to secure versus non secure so
what we mean by that is securing your
site we want to make it sure that
compliant with certain protocols and so
if we go back here we can see that this
particular site is compliant it is
secure HTTPS means it has a secure
license meaning the site is secure so
Google likes secure versus non secure so
non secure would be HTTP so we want
HTTPS as our protocol and what that
means is just enabling SSL Certificates
and that means when you enable an SSL
certificate that means your domain or
your protocol is going to be turned to
HTTPS so Google prefers sites that are
secure versus non secure so if you use H
ts as a protocol that adds an extra
layer of security over the HTTPS in HSTs
prevents cookie hijacking so adding
multiple layers of security always helps
in my opinion if you have an HTTP
website a non secure website you should
look into buying an SSL certificate
getting your sites flipped over to HTTPS
because what's gonna happen is your your
RAW structure is going to change when
your URL structure changes Google's
gonna recognize that because they're
gonna index your site and when they
index your site they're going to see
those secure URLs and that's gonna work
favorably in your favor and help you
rank higher on Google search so web
sites using secure or HTTPS have a
higher chance of ranking higher so HTTPS
is a ranking signal because Google
indexes those pages so let's also talk
about sitemaps so sitemap is one of the
most important ways to improve your
website ranking why well because
sitemaps are a way to organize all your
rels into one file so we're basically
going to prioritize all our web pages in
a sitemap so if you go to any particular
website and you type in sitemap XML
you're likely going to see all the pages
on your website so usually the sitemap
is located in the root directory so if I
type in sitemap XML I'm gonna be able to
see all the pages in my root directory
and I can also prioritize them I can
also alert Google as to how often they
change and every page is going to have a
date stamp associated with it so Google
can actually see how often it changes so
remember we want our content to be
updated frequently
so contents not updated frequently or
it's not fresh then Google is going to
see that size that that date stamped
that last modification did so we want to
be able to make sure our contents
updated frequently we want to let Google
know that we changed it frequently and
we want to be able to prioritize our
pages
Google no hey these pages are important
to us so all that can be set up in a
sitemap we want to be able to add
canonical versions of URLs and the
sitemap so we want to be able to add all
our original URLs in our sitemap and so
we always want to build dynamic URLs
sitemaps for larger websites and what I
mean by dynamic URLs that means that if
I look at this site map and we're always
adding content let's just say in the
form of a blog well guess what we want
those pages to be added to the sitemap
as they're published so as we add pages
to the blog or to the site then they
should automatically be added to the
sitemap and so in effect what's going to
happen is we're gonna be able to see the
sitemap grow with more URLs when the
sitemap grows with more URLs then that
means then Google's gonna index more
pages they're gonna index more fresh
pages so they're gonna be able to get
those pages that are just published
quicker so that's the whole idea behind
dynamic sitemaps is we want to be able
to capture all the URLs chesses are
published and we want to be able to
maintain our sitemaps and so I would
always recommend a dynamic sitemap but
you can always create your own sitemap
just by going to a tool called XML
sitemap so if I just type in XML
sitemaps into Google search here I could
see XML sitemaps generator and I can be
able if I have a small website just
create a free and simple sitemap on my
own when XML sitemaps creates it or your
platform creates a dynamic sitemap
either way the sitemap is going to sit
in the root directory and then what we
want to do in turn is like Google know
where that sitemap is so in search
console we want to be able to submit the
sitemap so you're gonna add the sitemap
you're gonna let Google know where it is
it should be in the root directory and
it should be called sitemap XML and when
you do that Google is going to be able
to take those URLs and index them so we
could see we submitted 528 URLs Google
index 521 so what
thing about URLs here is when we create
a sitemap we're putting all your URLs in
there we do not add no indexed URLs in
your sitemap and what that means is that
any URL we don't want Google to index
we're just going to exclude from the
sitemap okay so we want Google to take
all the URLs we want indexed and put
them in the sitemap so according to edgy
using side maps for SEO can increase
your website's visibility and help you
get indexed why because what you're in
fact doing is taking all your URLs that
you want indexed you're telling Google
how often they're modified you're
telling Google which ones are important
and you're submitting that to Google and
so Google's going to be able to take all
these URLs quicker index them quicker
and when they're indexed quicker you can
get ranked quicker and when you get
ranked quicker you can get traffic
quicker so that's the whole idea behind
sitemaps so let's turn our attention to
Page Speed now so when the last factors
for our website besides architecture
making it secure and adding sitemaps is
want to take a look at how quick our
pages load here are some tips in order
to optimize page speed because ideally
the quicker a page loads the more
engaged the users going to be
if it takes a longer time for the page
to load all the elements of that page
then what's going to happen is the user
is going to get impatient maybe leave
the website all together or go to
another page and so we want to be able
to optimize images so any image that's
of large size in terms of megabytes we
want to be able to optimize that
compress the image so that's one way to
speed up page speed we want to use a
simple website design you know HTML with
CSS or cascading style sheets just a
simple design with simple hierarchy and
website navigation structure so nothing
fancy nothing complex just a simple
website design with optimized images we
want to leverage browser caching and we
want to upgrade the server response time
meaning all your files are sitting on
the server so when somebody goes to web
page the server is sir
all of those files the images the texts
etc and so we want the server to respond
as quick as possible so when it comes to
PageSpeed we can look at the factors
affecting PageSpeed in Google Analytics
so if I go to Google Analytics and I go
under behavior and I go under site speed
and I go to overview I'm gonna be able
to see what my average load time is for
my site and ideally we want our pages to
load as quick as possible so that means
anything under four seconds anything
four seconds are higher and it's likely
the end user is going to leave the page
there's a correlation BP between page
load time and bounce rate and so what
Google actually does is give you speed
suggestions so if we do have a page that
loads slow we can just go to speed
suggestions in Google Analytics and we
go to speed suggestions then Google is
going to be able to tell us hey this
particular page load fast this potato
page load slow and if it loaded slow why
is it loading slow so here we could see
the home page of the example is loading
on average of seven seconds well if we
look here they're gonna give us some
suggestions so if I click on this
PageSpeed suggestions it's going to load
a report and a tool called PageSpeed
insights and basically what it's then
going to do after it's done running is
it's gonna tell me all the ways in which
I can optimize my pages not only for
desktop but also for mobile so here I
can see for desktop or from mobile I can
look at some ways in which I can
optimize it to increase page speed for
example sizing my images properly server
response time reducing my server
response time avoiding multiple page
redirects so there's a lot of
opportunities that we can do to peep
speed up page load time and all that's
found in PageSpeed insights and all
that's found within Google Analytics so
remember optimizing code minimizing
redirects optimizing your images
upgrading your server response and all
of those are factors and so again you
can go into analytics PageSpeed inside
and you could see exactly what Google is
recognizing as what's lowering or
slowing down your page load time so
Google takes site speed as one of the
most important ranking factors why
because they're going to rank pages not
only with high quality content that are
relevant to the keyword queries but they
want those pages to have a good user
experience so if somebody clicks on the
page then the user should be able to see
that content fairly quickly and so
that's why it's such an important factor
so the quicker your pages load the
chances of you ranking higher are gonna
be better so according to web
performance today Walmart as an example
experience to declining conversions so
what they did was looked at their page
speed and when they looked at their page
speed you'd be surprised what that did
just increasing it from one to four
seconds or decrease in it basically
increase conversion so there's always
going to be a correlation between how
quick a page loads and how engaged the
user is because if it's users engaged
they're gonna stay on the site and if
they stay on the site then their chances
of converting are gonna be higher so
just even one to two seconds increase in
page load is low time will make a world
of difference in terms of engagement in
conversions
it's our attention to off-site
engagement so previously we talked about
on-page elements and website factors
that affect our rankings for search
results but we also need to turn our
attention away from our website meaning
what we do on our website and turn our
attention what we can do for our website
off our website and on to other websites
so that's off side engagement and so
let's look at an example so that ice
cream recipes blog so we did everything
we possibly could we updated the meta
tags the title tag the meta description
we added h1 tags we've made sure the
site architecture was sound we submitted
a sitemap we we made sure the page load
was good and fast so we did all the
things we're supposed to do on our web
page but we're still not ranking well
what do we need to do well we need to
turn our
away from our website into other
websites we call this off side or off
page SEO and we need to basically
generate links from high quality sites
back to our site so if we've done
everything we can on our own website and
we're still not ranking where we want to
be well then we need to turn our
attention to other web sites and so if
we turn our attention other websites and
other websites that are relevant other
web sites that are quality web sites
that have high domain Authority then
we're going to see an increase in
rankings so it's just a matter of
getting quality links from quality
websites that are relevant that's what's
going to move the needle on search after
we've taken care of all the on-page
elements so more backlinks from high
domain authority results in higher
rankings SEO is a combination between
what we do on our website meaning
optimizing the page and making sure our
website has good site architecture and
follows the best practices in terms of
sitemaps and page load then we need to
turn our attention to the backlinking to
improve our domain authority so
according to backlinko analysis off site
engagement is one of the most important
elements for ranking number one in
google so you can't just focus your
attention on updating the title tag and
making sure the pages load fast you have
to turn your attention as well to
getting back links from high quality
sites that's off site engagement and so
gaining links backlinks from multiple
danes is vital it's vital because they
bring referring traffic to your site
they bring credibility to your site but
more importantly Google is going to
recognize the relationship between these
sites and your website and if these
sites that I have backlinks or links
pointing to your site and if they're of
high quality then we call that passing
link juice so it's going to bring
quality to you in terms of organic
search so if we look at an example if I
do a search
for banana bread recipe there 240 1
billion results for banana bread recipe
why did this particular page from simply
recipes ranked number one well we can
turn our attention to Moz and Massa has
a report called link Explorer and so Moz
link explorer report helps us identify
our own page Authority our own domain
Authority and how many links we have
from other quality websites so if I put
that particular URL into link Explorer
and notice the URL here is short even
though it uses an underscore when it she
use a - it's still ranked number one and
why because off page elements help this
page rank number one why their page
authority out of 100 is 58 their domain
authority out of 100 is 82 and what does
that mean well that means that they have
a lot of good links from other domains
of high quality they have 824 linking
domains to this one domain they have
3600 inbound links and two ranking for a
lot of different keywords so if we
scroll down we're going to be able to
see kind of a break out the quality of
websites that are linking to them so
they have 19 domains with a domain
authority of 91 to a hundred linking to
them they have fifteen domains between
the range of 81 and 90 so what does that
tell me between 15 and 19 that's thirty
four particular domains that are very
high quality linking to it and so we
could see the breakout of the linking
domains we could see the top file links
to the site and we could see the page
Authority so the link Explorer report
gives us an overview of what pages are
linking to ours and it also gives us an
idea of what our own page Authority and
domain Authority are because domain
Authority and page Authority both need
to be high in order for us to rank on
Google search in order for it to get
high
we need links from high quality sites so
that's the whole idea behind
side engagement so some of the off side
engagements are influencer marketing
meaning is there somebody out there on
social who has a huge following but not
only do they have a huge following but
are they relevant to our product for
example Hussein Bowe who's a famous
sprinter if we're selling shoes and
we're selling Nike shoes maybe Hussein
both can reference us on Twitter or
Facebook
that's influencer marketing getting
people to influencing people to buy our
product we can engage with audiences on
multiple social media platforms like
Facebook and Twitter
meaning if we're running a promotion on
those running shoes then we can promote
that on Facebook okay we can promote
that on Twitter we can also bookmark our
webpage on popular bookmarking sites
like stumble upon we can also put our
content on discussion forums like Reddit
we can join high PR quality a Q&A sites
excuse me and post answers to questions
related to our business like Korra calm
so we can engage in sharing our content
and answering questions so there's lots
of ways to get links to your website if
you have a blog post as an example you
can make sure that maybe that content is
shared on a similar blog post so if you
have an ice cream recipe blog post well
maybe you can look at a dessert blog
post and share your content on that
particular blog post and have a backlink
pointing from that blog post to yours as
an example and you can reciprocate so
the whole idea of content is sharing the
content but at the same time I shared it
you're producing backlinks and backlinks
help domain Authority so not only do
they help domain Authority but they
improve the search rankings so in
Google's eyes the higher your domain
authority higher the page Authority in
Google's eyes that means your page is
important it's credible and we're going
to improve it in the search engine
rankings
it increases brand visibility if we have
our content awning highly and
website a highly popular website or a
blog it's not it's gonna lift our brand
visibility if we have Hussein Baal who's
very famous sprinter do some influencing
marketing for us then that's gonna
increase our preamp his ability so
anytime we can associate with something
that has some influence or some clout or
high domain Authority then it's only
going to increase our brand awareness
and visibility so again it's going to
increase our domain authority because of
the association of passing link juice
from one domain to another it's going to
then as a result increase referral
traffic because if we're on a high
quality website that gets a lot of
traffic then the chances of some of that
traffic going our site's going to be
great and again it improves the
credibility and trust of our website and
that's what we want we want Google to
trust us and a way to build trust is by
associating our website with other
websites of high equal or higher quality
so when we talk about off-site
engagement we want to do some guest post
on relevant websites so if you have that
ice cream blog go to another blog like
the dessert blog and do a guest post so
not only that will that improve your
brand awareness but it'll generate a
backlink and maybe drive some referral
traffic you could participate in forums
and blog discussions like core calm or
reddit get your content out there start
a discussion about a specific topic to
engage users build brand awareness and
generate that backlink you can always
you know put your your site on a
directory like Yelp for example or Yahoo
directory you could prefer testimonial
link building meaning if you serve
products or offer up a service well
somebody can provide a testimony on
their website or you can just earn
backlinks from relevant authoritative
web pages just like we mentioned Cora or
Wikipedia or there's plenty out there so
the idea is to associate yourself with
high quality websites but do it
naturally you don't want to force
anything so if you're selling a specific
service or you're selling a specific
product look for like mining services or
products that complement what you do and
that'll create
natural environment natural ecosystem
that will eventually give you the
benefits that you need to rank higher in
the search results pages so we don't
want to purchase any links we don't want
a cloak content we don't want to just
inject links on sites that aren't
relevant we don't want to just have
site-wide links all over the place
pointing to the same page and we
certainly don't want to be on low
quality websites or directories it's all
about quality not quantity with off-site
engagement
so having off-site engagement
complements what you do on your website
for on-site together both of those
efforts will get you higher search
engine results let's go over some key
takeaways for today's session we started
out with the keyword research remember
with the keyword research it's all about
relevancy combined with volume and low
competition so that combination is going
to get you the keywords you need for
on-page optimization so use the tools to
do respose alike Google's keyword
planner Google's keyword planner is
going to give you the volume you need
use the the all in title syntax on
Google to get an idea of competition
cluster your keywords together in themes
like bread recipes look for a bunch of
keywords related to bread recipes if
that's what you're trying to optimize
for take the keywords that are going to
generate high-quality content so when
you pick good keywords that generate
high-quality content then focus on the
high quality content you want to start
with a good title you want to choose
keywords that are going to complement
the content that you can work into the
content naturally you can you know
organize the content by using headers
you can write your content so it's going
to be easy to understand right shorter
paragraphs incorporate images call-outs
videos you know mix it up a bit add CTAs
in there make it engaging answer the
users questions all of these are going
to contribute to good quality content
whole idea beyond good quality content
is to make sure
users are engaged because the more
engaging the content the better chance
you have to rank on Google so when you
create content they gives you the
opportunity to optimize that content and
by optimizing we mean working those
keywords naturally into the meta tags
the title tag in the meta description
you know work those keywords into the
header you know make sure the header is
short sweet concise but powerful and
makes sense it's relevant to the content
you make sure the URL is short but
readable and then we talked about off
page so off page elements for the
website
meaning submit the sitemap look in
Google Analytics at page load time make
sure your site's secure and once you do
all those things to your website all
those factors then you could turn your
entire attention to link building
off-site engagement we talked about
influence or marketing or or social
platforms or other websites that are
going to not only provide a link but
they're going to give you credibility
brand awareness they're going to refer
traffic to your website and then they're
going to overall improve your domain and
page authority so all those factors
combined are going to help you improve
your search engine rankings so thank you
for attending for more information
please visit simply learn com
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here